All right.
Good morning all.
Today we embark on another new
chapter in what we do.
And the topic is going to be --
We will talk about this thing
called an Operational Amplifier.
Before I get into the lecture,
I want to point out a couple of
things.
One is that you are going to
hear about two big words in
today's lecture.
Two big and incredibly
important words.
And I want to mention those
words to you right now so that
when I come to them in lecture
you can say OK,
I better pay really close
attention, these are important
words.
All right.
One of them is abstraction.
The second one is feedback.
Two incredibly important
concepts.
Abstraction,
you have been seeing a couple
times during this course,
once in the beginning where we
abstracted out Maxwell's
equations by focusing on a
smaller playground and simply
using KVL, KCL in place of those
equations.
A big abstraction.
It turns out that almost all of
EECS is based upon abstractions
at various levels.
In the first lecture,
I also showed you the layer
upon layer of abstraction that
we built to be able to build
interesting systems.
The second big thing is
feedback.
And I am going to relate this
to anti-lock breaks in cars.
And so, you can wait and see
how we do that.
It's an incredibly important
concept.
Before we dive into the
amplifier abstraction,
let me first talk about
something that you know.
Start with something that you
know and then lead up into the
operational amplifier and its
circuits.
You know about the MOSFET
amplifier.
The MOSFET amplifier that you
know about looked like this.
It was based on a MOSFET.
There was a VS supply.
There was a vI input,
a vO output and,
as I said, a VS supply.
So, this was a MOSFET circuit
that you've seen before.
One way of viewing this is that
this circuit has three major
ports.
This here is the input port
with voltage vI.
This here, between the drain
terminal and the ground,
is the output port.
I take the output between the
drain terminal and ground.
And, finally,
we have a third port,
which is this one.
It is called the power port.
I apply VS between this
terminal here and the ground
terminal.
And that gives us the power
port.
This device here was a three
port device.
Input port or control port,
output port and a power port.
And so we looked at the circuit
and did a whole bunch of
analyses of it.
Then what I can do at this
point, now that you've seen
this, it's often times
interesting to think about
abstracting this out into some
kind of a building block.
Much like in software,
you write a procedure and you
abstract out the internal
details of the procedure in the
procedure declaration and in the
call that you make.
In the same way,
we can take this little device
here and abstract that out into
the following abstraction.
We could abstract that out as a
device that looks like this.
I have my input port,
I have my output port and I
have my power port.
So, I can apply VS here.
Notice that I've taken these
six terminals here,
one, two, three,
four, five and six,
and put a box around it.
And just exposed the terminals
to you.
And I need to tell you a little
bit more about the internal
properties, but suffice it to
say that you can begin working
with this little block.
An even simpler version of this
for many applications might just
look like this,
vI and vO where there is a
ground that is shared among them
that is implicit in this
picture.
And vI and vO can simply be the
node voltages at these nodes.
This is a progressively more
abstract representation of this
amplifier.
What we can do is,
provided we know,
we can abstract out the
relevant properties of this
block and expose them outside.
And the relevant properties
might well be that,
let's say here the properties
may be that I in is always zero.
I can also express to you the
gain of this amplifier.
I may also be able to tell you
the Thevenin equivalent for the
output.
There are some properties that
I can give you that will let you
use this building block
abstractly.
Today, what we will do is
introduce a powerful abstraction
of a type of amplifier.
This is called the operational
amplifier or "op amp" for short.
What I am going to do is give
you a slightly more involved
building block than the one I
have shown you there.
But suffice it to say that the
idea is going to be the same.
This building block looks like
this.
This building block has an
input port.
This building block also has a
port in which to connect power
or the power port.
And the way I am going to
connect power,
I am going to connect a plus VS
supply here.
That is going to be my ground
node.
And I am going to connect a
minus VS supply to this node
here.
So, these voltages are both VS.
I want to apply a plus VS here
and a negative VS out here.
And I am going to take the
output between the ground node
and the output node of the
operational amplifier and call
that a vO.
This is the output port.
So, input port and output port
and a power port.
Think of this as a pattern
where I have an input port
across which I connect the
input.
I have a power port across
which I connect a plus VS,
minus VS supply,
and then I take the output
terminal and take a ground
terminal, which is defined by
external components of my
circuitry, and use this as my
reference node.
Remember ground is just a
I am going to use this as a
reference node.
These two are equal in
magnitude.
And take this as my output.
And when I do something like
this, I can build an even
simpler, so this is an abstract
differential input amplifier.
In other words,
this amplifier is going to
amplify whatever I apply at the
input.
A slightly more abstract
representation of this looks
like this.
vOUT and plus/minus vIN.
This is a slightly more
abstract representation where,
remember, we are going to draw
this again and again,
maybe at least 38 or 39 times
in this course.
And, remember,
each time you draw it,
remember that there is an
implicit power port,
a plus/minus supply that is
connected which we don't show.
And I remember when I first
learned about it a long time ago
there was a confusion in me
initially.
How does this work?
Where is the power coming from?
Just remember that power comes
from a plus/minus supply,
and we just don't show that in
this abstraction.
Now, the details,
a lot of details are in Chapter
16 of your course notes.
That's the reading for that.
The other thing is that there
are some other key properties of
this amplifier.
And let me discuss those very
quickly.
First of all,
I can draw a circuit model for
the amplifier.
Make some room for myself here.
And this is a circuit model for
what we call the ideal
operational amplifier.
And the circuit model is going
to look like this.
This is an abstract device.
And, in terms of analyzing how
this behaves in a circuit,
I am going to show you this
abstract circuit that looks as
follows.
Some input v is applied at
these two terminals here.
And this terminal is called my
v plus terminal and this is
called my v minus terminal,
so this corresponds to these
two terminals.
I am telling you that the
current going in is going to be
zero, so i plus is going to be
zero and i minus is going to be
zero.
i plus is the current in here
and i minus is the current into
the v minus terminal,
and both these currents are
going to be zero in this device
here.
The output is going to look
like this.
Let me just call it vOUT to be
consistent with this here.
And taken with ground as my
reference.
The output is simply Av.
In other words,
what I am doing is I am going
to model this as a device that
has a dependent source at its
output.
And the dependent source here
is a voltage controlled voltage
source.
It is a dependent source,
it is a voltage controlled
voltage source such that the
output voltage is A times the
voltage v across its input.
This is actually very simple.
Think of these three terminals
I have shown you here.
I applied input across these.
And the output is going to be A
times whatever I applied.
And A is going to tend towards
infinity.
A is going to be huge.
And specific values for A might
be a hundred thousand or a
million or things of that sort.
Huge A in this abstract
amplifier.
In addition to that,
the other properties are that
it is going to have infinite
input resistance.
That means looking in this
looks like an open circuit.
The fact that this is open here
implies the infinite input
resistance across this port.
What about the output here?
Remember, this is a voltage
source.
And we have a zero output
resistance, which means that no
matter how the load affects
this, as I apply a load this is
going to behave like an ideal
voltage source and keep holding
the voltage constant based on
whatever the function I
establish here.
And A is virtually infinite.
Let me pause there for a few
seconds and just dwell on this
so you just understand what the
basic device is.
Following this basic
definition, I am just going to
build a whole bunch of fun
little circuits.
The analysis will be pretty
straightforward,
but this is a big conceptual
leap here where there is some
circuitry inside.
Containing resistors,
MOSFETs, a whole bunch of stuff
in there.
I am not telling you what is
inside it.
Much like I could build an
abstract amplifier,
I could put an abstract box
around the amplifier you saw
earlier, I want to put a box
around some circuitry.
I am not telling you what the
circuitry is.
And, if you are curious,
you should look at page 581 of
your course notes.
There is an example solved.
The example is for a
differential amplifier.
This is the small signal
analysis chapter.
That differential amplifier
that's solved in that example is
usually the first stage in an
operational amplifier circuit.
That differential amplifier is
the first stage at the input.
And that differential
amplifier, as the name implies,
amplifies not a single voltage
but amplifies a differential
voltage.
Note that this guy amplifies
the voltage difference between
these two terminals.
That's v here.
And v is simply the same as v
plus minus v minus.
It's the node voltage here
minus the node voltage here.
That is what's amplified.
It amplifies a difference.
Therefore, it is called a
difference amplifier or a
differential amplifier.
And so that input stage is what
is inside the op amp.
It's got a bunch of other
circuitry like level shifters
and so on.
And at the output it has got a
buffer.
At at the output it has
something that is reminiscent of
the source follower circuit that
you learned about in
recitations, solved an example
in the course notes and in your
homework as well.
And you solved a variant of the
source follower on your quiz as
well in problem two.
So, a circuit that looks like
that appears at the output.
Remember, for the source
follower, the resistance looking
in from the output was very,
very small.
You have seen some of the
pieces that go inside the
amplifier, but we will deal with
this as a building block and
simply represent it using this
abstract little circuit.
To dwell on this a little
longer, this little device here
is the workhorse of the analog
industry.
Much like your primitive gate
abstraction, your inverter and
NAND gate and so on,
much as your primitive inverter
or NAND gate was from the
foundations of the digital
industry.
Remember we learned how to
build this little abstract
device called a NAND gate or an
inverter?
We noticed that those form the
foundations of very complicated
microprocessors.
Those were the building blocks
of the digital industry.
In the same way,
this little beast here is the
building block of the analog
industry.
Just to give you an analogy
from software,
think of this abstract little
device as a library routine from
a library of functions when you
program in C++ or whatever.
Can someone give me an example
of an incredibly popular routine
that we use all the time that
may be called the workhorse of
the software industry?
Pardon?
An abstraction,
an abstract procedure.
One example might be something
like a printf.
Printf is an abstract name for
a procedure that goes and does
something for you.
It is amazing how we take the
lowly printf for granted.
I stick my printf into my
program, it includes the
standard IO library and it goes
and prints a value.
You won't believe how
complicated the printf is.
As you go into learning more
advanced software subjects,
implementing the printf is a
nightmare.
It is horrendously complicated.
Just imagine.
You give it a string and it has
to go and print that on your
terminal or on your Windows
system or whatever.
Think of the complicated steps
it has to go through.
But, as far as you're
concerned, it's simple.
Just print out something and
you're done.
The same way.
Think of this as the printf of
the analog business.
It is really simple,
and the analysis is going to be
incredibly simple,
it will be mind-bogglingly
simple, but inside it,
heavens forbid if you look
inside it.
Tell you what,
go into to S-T-D-I-O dot in one
of the library routines and just
pore through printf.
The world's worst horrendous
macros are in there.
I mean it is just nasty.
The same way inside the op amp,
it is nasty.
You don't want to go there.
Much like in your C programming
in your classes,
you were able to use printf
without fully knowing how it was
implemented.
Probably some MIT god or some
key graduate implemented it,
but once it was implemented you
just used it based on simple
abstract rules as to how it
behaved.
You didn't have to know what
was inside it to use it.
The same way with the
operational amplifier.
So, just think of printf when
you see this and just imagine
how simple it is going to be to
use it.
You may think that I spend way
too much time,
ten minutes dwelling on this
abstract concept,
but I like to dwell on things
that I think are incredibly
important.
The concept of abstraction is
very important.
And it's not just in software.
The concept of abstraction
pervades all of EECS.
And if I were to give you a
project to say go and ask every
professor what is the one word
that you think best describes
all of EECS?
Just pick one word.
Go ask every single professor
you know.
What is a single word?
If you were to characterize all
of EECS with just one word,
what might that word be?
In my mind, it is the A word,
abstraction.
It is all over.
If you do a grep on all the
words used by all your
professors in your four years
here, I promise you the first
one will be know.
And the second one will be
abstraction.
Check it out.
See if what I am saying is true
or not.
It is all over the place.
In 6.001, how many times do you
think the word abstraction was
used in 6.001?
It's all over the map.
It's the A word all over.
Imagine your shock when you see
it being used in 002 because the
same concept applies.
We build more complicated
systems by abstracting out the
details of lesser objects,
and then using those to build
the more complicated systems.
Abstraction is a very powerful
mechanism of dealing with
complexity.
Next step is how do I go about
using the op amp?
Let me show you how it looks on
a scope.
What I am going to do is apply
input to the op amp,
I am going to look at the
output, place the resistor RL to
ground and look at the output.
And here I am going to apply a
plus VS and out here a minus VS.
Again, remember that a plus VS
simply looks like this and a
minus VS simply looks like this.
It's just an inverted VS
applied here so I get a minus VS
at this input.
First of all,
what I would like to do is as I
change vIN, I am going to plot
for you how vOUT looks.
vIN and this is vO.
I am going to plot vIN in terms
of microvolts and vO in volts.
vIN is going to have a very
very small, the scale is going
to be in microvolts because
remember the gain of this is
huge.
It's on the order of ten to the
sixth.
It's huge.
Small changes in vIN are going
to cause massive changes in vO.
I have a very fine scale on the
X axis.
What is going to happen if I
somehow magically make vIN
exactly zero?
If I short these two terminals,
if this was a completely ideal
op amp, which it never is,
if it's a completely ideal op
amp, then my output should be
zero.
As I increase my vIN the output
should be A times vIN.
For some small value of vIN,
small v, let's say one
microvolt, the output should be
one volt.
A is a constant so this would
look like a straight line.
And let's say my supply
voltages are 12 volts minus 12
volts, if this were an ideal
amplifier and I didn't have to
worry about the supply,
this would just go on extending
forever.
But I have a plus 12 volt
supply and a minus 12 volt
supply.
My output cannot go past those
limits.
And so, therefore,
my output kind of flattens out
at these two points.
And it is called hitting the
rails.
Output goes up and you hear a
thunk sound and you hit the
rails.
When you play with op amps in
your next lab,
if you listen really,
really carefully you may hear
it.
So, this saturates out.
Not surprisingly,
this region where the output
saturates at the supply is
called the saturation region.
Remember, don't confuse it
with-- It's not the same as your
saturation in the MOSFET.
It is a totally different
thing.
It is just happenstance that we
call this saturation.
And if you would like to think
about it, you can think of it as
the thunk region.
That's probably more
appropriate to distinguish it
from the saturation region in
the MOSFET.
And, not surprisingly,
this one is called the active
region.
And it is in this region that
we use the op amp.
Here it has hit the rails and
is kind of dangling out there.
It's not much use to us.
It's in this active region that
we use it because this is where
the gain is seen.
Now, it turns out that this is
a very high gain device.
It is very skittish.
This gain is kind of a really
funny thing.
It's dependent on a bunch of
factors.
This could be temperature
dependent.
This gain here and this curve
is just completely skittish.
It could depend on temperature.
It could depend on time of day.
It could depend on what
medication this amplifier is on.
It could depend on its mood
swings.
Who knows what?
This is kind of unstable.
And A in particular is highly
unstable.
It is going to be big,
that's for sure,
but it could be ten to the six,
on a rainy day it might be two
times ten to the six.
If it feeling sleepy it may be
point five times ten to the
sixth.
It is big but I cannot rely on
it.
Let me show you an example.
I want to show you this curve
for this MOSFET,
apply an input and plotting the
output.
What I will do is take a look
at this curve.
Then what I am going to do is
use a heat gun to heat the op
amp and you are going to see
this vary all over the map.
If you still remember last
week, some of you may remember
that from some place in a
similar situation where the gm
for the MOSFETs you were given
was also dependent on
temperature and stuff like that.
It is a very common occurrence.
And that is certainly the case
for the MOSFET.
Let's apply input.
Let's do this.
This is vIN versus vOUT for the
amplifier.
Notice that this is plus 12
volts, this is minus 12 volts.
It is about two volts per
division.
This axis here is in
microvolts, I believe.
For a very small change,
for a few tens of microvolts,
I have an incredibly high gain.
Notice that this has an
incredibly high gain here.
The gain is the slope of this
line, almost a vertical line.
What I am going to do next,
is to have some fun,
is I am going to heat the op
amp.
To show you that A is kind of
really skittish and also the
fact that it doesn't quite hit
zero, it does all kinds of weird
things, I am going to heat the
op amp.
And then let's take a look at
how that curve fluctuates.
What you saw there was that the
op amp began to behave really
weirdly as I heated it.
Instead of doing this it
sometimes did this really
weirdly, like getting an offset
from the center and so on.
And it does a bunch of other
weird things,
but we won't go into those
details.
It's not relevant for this
course.
But the point is that the gain
and the offset at the input are
dependent on temperature.
And we look for ways to make it
less dependent on temperature.
As the next step,
what I would like to do is
build a circuit.
This is model equivalent of
your Hello World program.
We are going to use the printf
and build a small program on the
printf.
You don't have to worry about
how printf is implemented,
just that we can build very
highly interesting circuits with
this horrendously complicated
function based on a simple
abstraction of the device.
The circuit that we will build
is called a noninverting
amplifier.
From now on,
I am not going to show you the
plus/minus VS.
I am not going to show the
power port, but it is in there.
It's hidden under the
abstraction layer.
This is my op amp.
And I am going to build the
following circuit.
This is my v plus and this is
my v minus.
What I am going to do is for
the v plus I shall apply a vIN.
Let me talk a little bit about
ground as well.
Ground is commonly taken as the
point at which I connect my VS
and minus VS supply.
It is kind of at the midpoint.
And if VS and minus VS are very
carefully tuned then the output
is also going to be at that same
ground reference when the input
is zero.
So, the ground is defined as
the point at which I connect my
plus/minus VS supplies.
I apply my vIN out here.
Then what I am going to do,
here is my output vO.
I am going to have a resistive
divider to ground here and label
these R1 and R2.
And what I am going to do here
is feed this back to the input,
to the v minus input.
I am going to sample the
voltage here and feed that into
here.
So, this is my abstract model
and this is my Hello World
program.
What we are going to do is
simply analyze how this little
program behaves.
So, my equivalent circuit
model.
The way to analyze these is
after one or two of these
examples, you will be able to
directly analyze this just by
looking at it,
by inspection.
But, much as we did for the
other pieces,
let me grunge through drawing
the equivalent circuit and
grinding through the analysis,
and then show you the much
simpler way of doing it.
And even here,
even with this grinding
analysis, it is going to be
pretty simple in any case.
So, I will replace the op amp
with its equivalent circuit
model.
Its equivalent circuit was v
plus, v minus.
So, that was the equivalent
circuit model of the operational
amplifier, just this piece.
I draw that for you.
Then what I am going to do is I
connect my v in here.
And, remember,
I have an R1,
R2 resistive divider here.
And this one gets connected to
this terminal there.
I also know that i plus is
zero.
I also know that i minus is
All I've done is simply
replaced the amplifier with its
equivalent circuit.
Let's go ahead and analyze that
circuit now.
circuit.
And it's going to be pretty
simple, actually.
What I am going to show you is
the hard way of doing it.
I will show you a much easier
way, but the hard way itself is
pathetically easy.
What I want to do is find vO in
terms of vIN.
And there will be a bunch of
other factors thrown in,
including things like R1 and
R2, A and stuff like that.
Let's go and analyze it.
vO, let's look at that circuit.
By the way, let me take 30
seconds and make a little speech
at this point.
When you see circuits like
this, and I saw this happen in
quiz two as well,
for some reason,
when you see a new kind of
circuit, don't completely go
berserk or freeze or whatever.
There is just no reason to.
You know the node method.
The node method is the
workhorse of our business.
When in doubt apply the node
method.
It will simply work.
Don't freeze.
Don't think oh,
man, I need to apply a pattern
that I know already.
I must have seen this
somewhere.
When in doubt boom,
apply the node method.
This circuit here,
all I have here is one unknown
node voltage.
I know the voltage of v plus,
I need to compute the voltage
vO.
There are two unknowns,
vO is an unknown and the
voltage here at v minus is
another unknown.
This is a very simple circuit
involving a dependent voltage
controlled voltage source,
and you need to find out vO and
v minus using the node method.
Just apply it.
It's simple.
Don't freeze.
Just look at it and say I can
do it and apply the node method.
It will simply work.
So, let's do that.
What I can do here is vO is A
times v plus minus v minus.
This is actually really simple.
And then, if I take v plus
here, I know v plus is simply
vIN so I will just make that
substitution right away.
So, v plus is simply vIN.
What is v minus?
v minus here is vO --
What is v plus?
I'm sorry, v minus.
v minus is simply the voltage
that is between R1 and R2.
Notice that no current flows in
to the v minus node.
There is no current flowing in.
Voltage at v minus is simply
the voltage given by the
resistive divider,
which is vO times R2 divided by
R1 plus R2.
Stare at that for another
second.
The voltage at this node here
is simply given by the resistive
divider.
Because no current is flowing
in this direction.
And no current flows in because
I am telling you there is no
current there based on my
abstraction.
I am telling you i minus is
zero.
That voltage is simply the
voltage at this resistive
divider.
And so I can simplify it
further and write this as vO.
So I get, there is a one here.
And I move this thing over to
this side so I get one plus A
times R2 divided by R1 plus R2.
And that is equal to AvIN.
And simplifying it some more,
I get vO is AvIN divided by one
plus AR2 divided by R1 plus R2.
Notice how simple this is,
and this is the hard method.
All I have done is analyze the
circuit using the basic circuit
analysis principle that you
learned the first week of the
course, and I have the output
for you.
I just noted very carefully
what the relationships were
between the various elements in
the abstraction.
Notice here that I am told that
A is extremely large.
A is on the order of ten to the
six and so on.
And suppose it is the case
that, let me write that down
again.
vO is AvIN, one plus AR2,
R2.
Suppose R1 and R2 are more or
less comparable and A is ten to
the six, it's a huge number,
so this whole number is much,
much greater than one.
If it is much huger than one,
what I can do is I can then
write this as follows.
I can say that this is more or
less equal to AvIN divided by
AR2 divided by R1 plus R2.
I am ignoring the one here.
As soon as I do that,
notice I can cancel out A and I
get vO to be approximately equal
to vIN times R1 plus R2 divided
by R2.
Notice now that when the gain
is very large the output is a
function of the input multiplied
by some number.
The beauty of this thing here
is that when A is very large,
or this expression is very
large, A cancels out and there
is no A in this relationship.
This means that even though the
basic amplifier was very
skittish, the output here
relates to the input based on
components that I have control
over.
These are soldiers in my army.
I control them.
So, to give you a sense of some
numbers here,
suppose A was ten to the six.
And I choose R1 to be 9R.
And R to be some R.
Then vO is ten to the sixth vIN
divided by one plus ten to the
six R divided by 9R plus R.
So, that is ten to the six vIN
divided by one plus ten to the
six divided by ten.
All right.
If I ignore the one here,
the ten to the six and ten to
the six cancel out,
this ends up giving me 10vIN.
So, I get a really nice
amplifier whose output is simply
ten times the input and
determined solely by some
resistor values.
Let me show you another quick
demo this time and show you the
amplifier again,
but with resistors connected
like that.
And then I show you that I want
to heat the amplifier to the
wazoo, the op amp to the wazoo,
but vO is going to be
absolutely rock solid.
Let's try that out.
This time around,
this is the transfer function,
the vO versus vIN.
And notice that this time
around I have similar scales on
the X and Y axes,
and this has a slope of 10.
This is the point where the
amplifier saturates at plus 12
volts, and this is minus 12
volts, and this point here is a
zero.
So, this is vIN,
vOUT, plus 12,
minus 12 and this slope is 10.
What I am going to do now is
heat the op amp to the wazoo and
this ain't going to change
because it's my external
resistors that control it
independent of the value of A,
provided A continues to be very
large.
I am just articulating the
vOUT, vIN curve.
And let me start heating the op
amp.
Notice that it's pretty stable.
It doesn't change because it is
independent of the amplifier
values.
What I have done now is by
connecting these resistors in
this way, I have a nice
amplifier with a gain of ten.
The question you may ask
yourselves is why?
There is this little sucker in
there that wants to shoot things
up by ten to the sixth.
Wants to knock things off the
one rail or the negative rail.
Why is it that it's behaving
like a docile lamb here and
giving us a nice little factor
of ten gain no matter what I do
to it?
Why is it doing that?
What is the intuition behind
it?
I will draw something on the
board, but for the next ten
seconds I want you think about
it.
See if you can come up with
some insight as to why is it
doing that.
Why is it exactly ten?
Why isn't the ten to the sixth
kind of killing me somehow?
Why am I getting exactly ten no
matter what happens?
See if you can come up with
some intuition and then I will
show you how it works.
I will redraw the circuit in
the meantime.
Let me see if I can give you
some intuition.
This is my circuit,
and let's say this is R and
this is R.
As an example,
let's assume that the input is
5 volts, vIN is 5 volts.
If R and R are equal,
what should the output be?
It's R and R,
so it's R1 plus R2 divided by
R2, right?
It's 2R divided by R,
so it has a gain of two.
My amplifier has a gain of two
because R1 plus R2 divided by
R2, which is my gain,
is R plus R divided by R equals
two.
So, this will be 10 volts.
If that is 10 volts this is
going to be 5 volts,
correct?
This R and R,
voltage divider,
this is five,
so I get 5 volts here.
This is v plus.
This is v minus.
I get R and R,
5 volts here,
that's how the circuit looks.
Now let's understand what is
going on.
And listen very carefully.
This is going to be a key
insight that I hope you will
carry with you for the rest of
your lives.
This is really,
really key.
What you are going to see is,
I think, the third big ah-ha
moment in 6.002.
Like small signal analysis,
like the frequency domain stuff
we saw, I think this is the
third big one in the next 30 or
40 seconds, things that are
completely either not
necessarily intuitive but are
just spectacular in terms of
what they can do for you.
Let's see.
Let's suppose that because I am
heating it, let's suppose that A
suddenly tends to increase.
It wants to increase because I
have heated it.
A is saying I want to get out
this mold here and starts to
break through its shackles here.
Let's say, as a Gedanken
experiment, that it tries to
shoot up this to 12 volts.
It tries to push it up higher.
This is just a Gedanken
experiment.
The up arrow says that the
increase in A is trying to push
up vO momentarily.
Let's see what happens.
It is trying to push up vO
momentarily, so let's say this
goes to 12 hypothetically.
If that goes to 12,
what should this volt node go
to?
Six, exactly.
This goes to 6 volts.
If that goes to six,
what does v minus go to?
6 volts again.
So, v minus goes to 6 volts.
Now at the input I have 5 volts
at v plus and 6 volts at v
minus, so where should the
output go?
The output should go down
because the voltage of the
negative terminal is higher.
And so the output is A times v
plus minus v minus.
And because this has gone down,
this has gone up here it is
going to try to pull the output
down.
That is going to pull the
output down let's say to 9 volts
or something.
Cachunk, there is a big battle
going on here.
A has gone up,
it has boosted it up to 12,
but the moment that goes to 12,
this goes to 6,
and the op amp output has to go
down to 9 volts now because this
input is higher here.
If this goes to 9,
this goes to 4.5.
If that goes to 4.5,
What happens now?
If this goes to 4.5,
what happens?
It wants to go back up.
Can't it make up its mind?
This guy wants to go back up
now because v plus is higher
than v minus.
What am I seeing here?
This whole circuit here behaves
like my little son,
my 9-year-old.
If say do this,
he wants to do the exact
opposite.
So, there is a trick in how you
make them do things for you.
Look at this.
Because of this arrangement of
the circuit when A tries to push
the output up,
the rest of the circuit tries
to pull it back down to where it
used to be.
If the circuit tries not to
follow the true path,
the rest of the circuit tries
to whack it into shape so it
follows a true path.
And what's happening is
because, in this arrangement,
I have fed back a portion of
the output to the negative
input.
I have fed back some of the
output to the negative input.
And by providing this feedback
of a portion of the output to
the negative input,
I have arranged it in a way
that I have something called
negative feedback.
What negative feedback does is
that if this wanted to go wild
and crazy, the circuit provides
it with some negative feedback
like you just saw.
Feedback, a big word.
If you take a poll of all the
EECS faculty,
I suspect that feedback would
rank at least as the ninth or
tenth most important word in the
EECS.
If abstract is number one,
I think this would rank like a
nine or a ten or something.
So, that's the reason why it
worked.
In the last couple of minutes,
let me give you some insight,
based on something that you
know, on how feedback works.
This is a road here.
Let's look at anti lock breaks.
This is my tire.
And let's say I have a set of
disk brakes here.
As the car is moving forward,
if I apply the brakes the tire
stops rolling,
but if I apply the breaks too
hard it can lock up the tire and
the whole car can skid.
The way anti lock breaks work
is as follows.
There is a controller that sits
here.
And there is a little person
looking at the wheel and seeing
is it turning.
So, this is a feedback.
And it is saying is it turning?
Yes.
Or, is it not turning?
No.
All this person watching the
tire is doing is saying is it
turning or is it not turning.
That is it.
That is a negative feedback.
And so, if it is no and if it
is yes.
If it is yes then what this
does is it applies the brakes
even more strongly.
It is turning so I can apply
more brakes.
But if it says oops,
it stopped turning,
what it does is it simply
releases, the controller
releases the brakes.
And when the controller
releases the brakes this one
tends to loosen up a little bit
and the tire starts turning
again.
So, this way you are constantly
keeping the tire in its region
of critical friction so that it
is constantly moving.
And static friction applies to
how hard you can brake and it
doesn't start skidding.
In fact, if you take your car
out, and I don't say you do
this.
Let's say go onto the Charles
River in the dead of winter and
you drive on the lake and you
slam your anti lock brakes on,
on an icy patch,
you will notice that there is a
constant sound that looks like
something is vibrating in there.
That is exactly what is
happening.
Oops, the tire is locked.
Release the brakes.
The wheel is turning.
Jam the brakes on.
That is exactly what is
happening.
The same way as out there,
you notice that oops,
the output is going up,
pull it down,
oops, it's going down,
pull it up.
So, there is constant negative
feedback that is keeping the
output stable.
A very important concept.
And I will ask your recitation
instructors to cover the very
simple method that is on page 9.